1600 policiers et gendarmes
supplémentaires pour contrôler les
frontières et les infrastructures de
transport c'est l'annonce qu'a fait
Bernard casenu ministre de l'Intérieur
au lendemain des attentats survenus à
Bruxelles les transports sont à présent
la priorité numéro 1 dans les gares les
contrôles sont renforcés comme à
Versailles chantier où la direction
départementale de la sécurité publique
augmente sa visibilité notre objectif
ici dans la gare des Chantiers c'est à
la fois de sécuriser la zone et
d'apporter un petit peu de d'assurance
aux gens qui emploient et qui utilisent
les transports en commun en ce moment je
pense que les français ce qui demandent
c'est de voir des policiers dans les
gares dans les transports en commun donc
c'est exactement pour ça qu'on est
présent un peu plus massivement que
d'habitude dans ce genre d'endroit comme
après les attentats survenus à Paris en
novembre et en janvier dernier cette
présence s bien accueilli par les
usagers des transports voir des
policiers tous les jours dans les gardes
tout ça bah oui ça me rassure parce que
avec les attentats qui se passent en ce
moment on sait pas ce qui peut se passer
par rapport à la menace qui pèse
aujourd'hui sur le pays c'est plutôt
rassurant de voir effectivement tous ces
militaire un petit peu partout c'est
rassurant je pense que voir les
policiers faire leur travail pour nous
protéger c'est une bonne chose des
équipes supplémentaires qui s'ajoutent
aux 5000 policiers et gendarmes déjà
mobilisés sur 220 points de contrôle aux
frontières Bernard casneu a demandé à
tous les préfets de renforcer la
sécurité notamment en Île-de-France où
400 policiers et gendarmes
supplémentaires ont été affectés pour
assurer une vigilance renforcée en ce
moment on fera attention aux gens qui
ont des gros des grosses valises des
colis qui peuvent paraître préparés de
manière un petit peu particulière euh on
va pas divulguer les secrets de fabrique
mais c'est évident que le sens de
l'observation du policier est mis à rue
d'épreuves en ce moment et ce qu'on
demande à nos collaborateurs c'est de
surveiller ce qui se passe le
comportement des passagers et de essayer
d'intercepter celui qui pourrait être un
peu bizarre dans la masse les mesures de
contrôle et de palpation devraient
également s'intensifier le niveau actuel
du plan Vigipirate alerte attentat le
plus élevé est toujours maintenu en île
de
France